let's make salt and pepper shrimp
this should take you less than 30
minutes to make and it's so good trust
me okay for this recipe the first thing
you have to do is toast your black
pepper some recipes ask you to toast the
salt as well but personally I did not
taste any difference if you toast it or
not so if you want to save gas or
electricity listen to me but it's up to
you but it's essential to toast the
peppers it just elevates the flavor
alright for the next step in cornstarch
coat the shrimp just like that I also
got some sweet cherry peppers we're also
going to lightly coat this in cornstarch
fry the peppers first
then we are going to fry the shrimp
we're gonna toss it in our toasted black
pepper also in some kosher salt
in our crispy cherry peppers for the
garnish
sometimes simple truly is the best